foreign
ERS love postgres and so do we at Google
Cloud
postgres has everything you would expect
from an open source database Rich
functionality and extensibility a
thriving ecosystem and open and
welcoming community and the portability
it offers to Enterprises and developers
all with no vendor lock-in
we have a lot of customers on postgres
and they tell us that at times there is
too much burden on them to make it run
well in production and they need to make
difficult trade-offs between reliability
cost and performance additionally
Enterprise customers moving from Legacy
proprietary databases expect additional
support in managing and scaling their
applications postgres is awesome it's
just that customers asked for our help
to solve some of these operational
problems and also Infuse AI nml to
improve their experience
so we started with the most loved
relational database postgres and brought
to it even more goodness from Google
like complete disaggregation of compute
and storage our knowledge of operating
databases and in-memory columnar engine
to accelerate analytics and our DNA of
AI and ml we introduced these
Innovations in alloy DB for postgres a
fully managed postgres compatible
database for your most demanding
Enterprise workloads loadb combines the
best of Google with postgres for
Superior performance scale manageability
and availability
alloy DB is more than four times faster
than standard postgres for transactional
workloads and delivers up to 100 times
faster analytical queries than standard
postgres
our customers love the scale performance
and manageability of lodb they showed
tremendous interest in migrating
completely off Legacy proprietary
databases to alloy DB and they asked us
to help them accelerate their legacy
database modernization by bringing a
fully supported alloy DB Edition to
wherever their workloads run whether
on-premises at the edge or in other
clouds we are excited to share that
alloy DB Omni is now in public preview
alloy DB Omni is a downloadable edition
of alloy DB designed to run on premises
at the edge across clouds and even on
developer laptops lodb Omni offers the
alloy DB benefits you have come to love
including high performance full postgres
compatibility and Google Cloud support
all at a fraction of the cost of Legacy
databases and for the public preview we
have made it easier to rapidly build
generative AI apps and easier to manage
your lodb Omni databases
Omni is powered by the same engine as
the cloud-based alloy DB service
lodb Omni is more than two times faster
than standard postgres for transactional
workloads and delivers up to 100 times
faster analytical queries than standard
postgres
for the public preview we have added
support for the PG Vector postgres
extension to make it easy to rapidly
build generative AI apps this includes
high performance PG Vector compatible
Vector search that is up to 10 times
faster and supports 4 times larger
vectors compared to standard postgres
alloy DB Omni automates embedding
generation to easily transform
operational data into Vector embeddings
speeding up your gen AI app development
and we have published detailed technical
guides to achieve high levels of data
protection using a combination of Open
Source tools and Google supported
configurations
we have added compatibility with
postgres 15 and we have included
utilities and a command line interface
to make it easier to manage your alloy
DB Omni databases and easier to
communicate configuration information to
Google support
in addition we are announcing support
for Alloy DB Omni as another choice in
database service for Google distributed
Cloud hosted are air-gapped private
Cloud for regulated customers delivering
a scalable fully possible compatible
database that also comes with Enterprise
support from Google
alloy DB Omni meets you where you are
and can take you where you need to go in
your database modernization Journey the
public preview is available for download
at no cost try it today thank you